endlich hat die quälende ungewissheit
ein ende die neue gruppe kommt ja dafür
dafür noch mal vielen dank an die
spd-basis seit heute kennen wir das
komplette kabinett wissen sie die sozen
haben ihre minister vorgestellt und von
wegen
diese regierung steht für kein neuanfang
freunde es ist der wahnsinn was die sich
für die nächsten vier jahre vorgenommen
haben du da kommen sie nie drauf wir
haben uns vorgenommen ein gutes team
aufzustellen das hervorragend
zusammenarbeiten kann und dass
gleichzeitig auch in der lage ist die
aufgaben zu lösen die dann von uns
insgesamt gelöst werden sollen
das ja mein ansatz nicht mal was anderes
aufgaben lösen ist noch nie probiert
worden
überlegt mal die haben nicht mal ein
rentenkonzept das über 2025 hinaus geht
wollen aber aufgaben lösen was sie haben
ist tatsächlich ein superteam heiko maas
zum beispiel ist unser neuer
außenminister und als formales ihnen
vorgestellt hat heute gab es einen
wunderschönen kleinen macho moment
zwischen heiko und dem olaf und zwar
beim stichwort standfestigkeit
diplomatisches geschick hat er auch als
justizminister immer wieder bewiesen
aber auch standfestigkeit und eine frau
aus
für schoko großartig allerdings die
entscheidung für franziska giffey als
neue familienministerin
die hat kein witz erst vorgestern noch
als bürgermeisterin neu sanierte
schultoiletten in berlin oder köln
eingeweiht also endlich mal eine frau
mit praxiserfahrung eine pragmatische
macherin hier sorgt sich auf einem
neuköllner schule für ordnung ohne
ironie eine sehr gute wahl
harter tag allerdings für sigmar gabriel
eiskalt gefeuert als außenminister gut
hatte sie natürlich auch zum teil selber
eingebrockt er wollte zum beispiel nie
antreten als kanzlerkandidat und hat
dann hat dann schultz vor geschickt hat
wir wissen alle wie das ausgegangen ist
und dann hat er noch den todesstoß
versetzt mit seinem zitat mit dem mann
mit dem gesicht in den haaren
missverständnis ein missverständnis das
ist der mann mit den haaren im gesicht
das gesicht in den haaren ist toni
hofreiter
aber wir kommen vom tierpark gekommen
könig zum thema andere geschichte
nein es geht natürlich um die ewige
groko ich kann die spd was ich kann die
spd-basis ja sogar verstehen dass man
nach dieser regierungsbildung sagt es
soll einfach nur aufhören aber
langfristig ist kroko halt gibt die
ränder werden stärker unsere österreich
werbung schreitet voran
ist halt so große koalition erfordert
große kompromisse immer und angela
merkel schließt endlich zu kohl und
adenauer auf demnächst 16 jahre im amt
diese woche hat sie zum zwölften mal die
tourismusbörse in berlin eröffnet und
man merkt einfach die frau ist immer
noch heiss
[Musik]
ja alles platt deutsches lied heißt
übersetzt so viel wie kommen die
nächsten vier jahre kriegen wir auch
noch um immerhin jetzt gibt es eine
bundesregierung mit vielen neuen köpfen
muss man anerkennen dorothee bär zum
beispiel unsere wäsche neue
staatsministerin für digitales und die
geht gleich in die vollen
deutschland ist zwar europaweit
schlusslicht bei glasfaser mit solchen
kleinigkeiten hält die doro sich gar
nicht auf wie denkt schon viel weiter
das thema muss doch sein kann ich auf
dieser infrastruktur die wir haben dann
auch mal autonom fahren habe ich die
möglichkeit auch zb mit einem flug taxi
durch die gegend zu können
richtig
flug taxi oder wie man in bayern sagt
seilbahn
warum nicht ein bisschen voraus denken
nächste woche wird also unsere kanzlerin
wieder mal vereidigt zum ersten mal und
dann ist die afd offiziell
oppositionsführer im bundestag
herzlichen glückwunsch auch zur
schlagzeilen produktion diese woche
fleißig sind sehr schon andre poggenburg
zb muss in sachsen-anhalt zurück treten
unter anderem wegen seinem ekelhaften
türken kameltreiber spruch und eine
abordnung von afg abgeordneten war auf
staatsbesuch in syrien die hander
vertreter des assad-regimes getroffen
und diese mörder ernsthaft gefragt ob
sie vielleicht ein paar flüchtlinge aus
deutschland zurücknehmen würden fragen
kostet nichts